town chicago yes for a great event  raising funds for the first mega dawa  center in america with our brother eddie  from the dean show sheikh khan was eight  is going to be out there august 28 6 pm  at the quran academy orland park  inshallah we want to see you out there  if you want to know more about it check  out the deenshow.com  events and register at the deanshow.com  you can register now i want to see all  of you out there i we got a lot of  requests from chicago well i'm coming  out to see you and this is a great cause  for the future of america for the dawah  in america for the hundreds of millions  of people that live in america and in  the west to know about islam we want to  build the first mega dawah center in  america with our brother eddie from the  dean show so we'll see you there  inshaallah august 28 6 pm we have a  dinner